Olá tudo bem Aqui o Dr aulan Machado
Dutra médico há mais de 25 anos e hoje
eu vou falar sobre um tema delicado
extremamente importante histórias das
falhas da Indústria Farmacêutica que
resultaram em graves consequências paraa
Saúde ao longo da história testemunhamos
inovações extraordinárias que salvaram
muitas vidas medicamentos como a
penicilina adrenalina por exemplo que em
situações críticas reverteram casos
graves de alergias e infecções que
poderiam ser fatais no entanto Apesar
desses sucessos não podemos fechar os
olhos para os erros significativos
cometidos hoje eu vou contar para vocês
sobre cinco medicamentos que causaram
sérios problemas de saúde e até mortes
resultando em sua proibição ou uso muito
limitado infelizmente a busca constante
por lucro Especialmente nos tratamentos
de doenças crônicas que podem exigir uso
contínuo muitas vezes na história
comprometeu a ética e a segurança dos
pacientes mas é essencial lembrar
pessoal se você está em tratamento e faz
uso contínuo de qualquer medicamento
nunca interrompa sem antes consultar o
seu médico a interrupção indevida de
medicações também pode causar efeitos
graves e vários problemas Ok vamos então
começar medicamento dois
talidomida O Legado de um remédio Mágico
pessoal no final dos anos 50 1950 um
medicamento chamado talidomida foi
lançado ao mercado pela kem grun nental
como a solução para náuseas dores de
cabeça e insônia promovida como
medicamento mágico e disponível sem
receita a talidomida rapidamente se
tornou uma sensação especialmente entre
as gestantes a quem prometia alívio dos
desconfortos da gravidez a marca
contergan primeiro nome sobre o Qual a
talidomida foi vendida não demorou a se
tornar líder de vendas na Europa
Especialmente na Alemanha seu país de
origem no Brasil o medicamento foi
comercializado como sedal entre outros
nomes mas sob a fachada de segurança e
eficácia escondia-se uma terrível
verdade a talidomida causava
malformações fetais severas pessoal o
problema dessa medicação anunciada como
a solução para as náuseas de insônia nas
estantes estava justamente no seu uso
durante a gravidez logo os primeiros
relatos de bebês nascendo com múltiplas
deformidades começaram a aparecer a
focomelia é uma malformação grave que
resultava em braços e pernas atrofiados
e frequentemente deformados foi uma das
mais comuns resultantes dos efeitos
terríveis desse remédio havia também
relatos e malformações em órgãos
internos a talidomida foi criada pelo
médico alemão hinrich mcter que
participou dos experimentos onde
remédios e vacinas inventadas por ele
foram testadas em prisioneiros sem
consentimento levando Muitos à morte em
1959 um jornal alemão reportou que 161
bebês haviam sido adversamente afetados
pela talidomida forçando os fabricantes
a acessar a sua distribuição na Alemanha
e na Inglaterra apesar de banida em
vários países no início da década de 60
no BR o medicamento só foi retirado do
mercado em 65 o saldo dessa tragédia foi
devastador mais de 10.000 crianças
afetadas em todo o mundo das quais
apenas cerca de metade sobreviveu a
repercussão foi tão grande que muitas
das vítimas Sobreviventes recebe até
hoje uma denização vitalícia do governo
alemão incluindo brasileiros pessoal
estee Capítulo Sombrio na história dos
medicamentos serve como lembrete da
importância da ética e da Vigilância
rigorosa de aprovação de medicamentos
medicamento número 3 viox
rofecoxib A História de um escândalo
farmacêutico em
1999 a Indústria Farmacêutica
testemunhou o lançamento do viox
fabricado pela merc um antiinflamatório
que prometia revolucionar o tratamento
de dores crônicas especialmente
relacionadas à artrite rapidamente o
medicamento escalou as listas de mais
vendidos ao redor do mundo aclamado por
sua eficiência no entanto o brilho dessa
nova estrela farmacêutica começou a se
ofuscar já no ano seguintes ao seu
lançamento quando relatos alarmantes e
médicos começaram a surgir associando o
viox a um risco significativamente
aumentado de doenças cardíacas um grande
estudo chamado vigor patrocinado pela
própria farmacêutica confirmou esses
temores ao revelar um aumento de 500% no
risco de ataques cardíacos entre os
usuários do medicamento contudo os
resultados foram manipulados na sua
apresentação ao público numa tentativa
Clara de minimizar o impacto negativo
sobre as vendas aqueles pesquisadores
que usaram levantar a voz sobre os
perigos foram perseguidos de maneira
impiedosa instituições foram ameaçadas
com cortes de financiamento caso não se
lance assem os seus críticos internos
uma estratégia que mantinha a verdade
longe do alcance do público os efeitos
devast do viox não demoraram a se
manifestar em escala Global durante os 5
anos em que foi comercializado
livremente estima-se que ao menos
47.000 pessoas morreram ou sofreram
danos irreversíveis devido à medicação
esses números são ainda mais impactantes
quando consideramos que tudo ocorreu sob
o olhar das regulamentações oficiais
estudos adicionais incluindo um
encomendado pela fda a agência
reguladora de medicamentos dos Estados
Unidos sugere que o viox pode ter sido
responsável por até
140.000 casos de doença coronarianas só
nos Estados Unidos desde seu lançamento
em terras brasileiras o viox conquistou
o mercado pouco antes de ser retirado
das Prateleiras interrompendo 20 anos de
liderança do Cataflan custando 1 bilhão
de dólares para desenvolver e gerando
receitas de 1,2 bilhão por ano o
medicamento Pareceu ser um sucesso
financeiro inquestionável mesmo a após a
empresa concordar em pagar 4,8 bilhões
indenizações em 2007 ainda reportou
lucro de 3,3 bilhões naquele ano a
revelação final veio quando documentos
judiciais mostraram que a farmacêutica
estava ciente dos riscos associados ao
viox muito antes deles se tornarem
públicos uma verdade sombria que
ressalta a necessidade de uma vigilância
mais rigorosa da Indústria Farmacêutica
medicamento quatro avandia ou Rose glitz
a pí da Esperança transformada em
desilusão lançado em 99 o avandia
prometia ser a solução para o Diabetes a
promessa era tão grande que rapidamente
o avandia se tornou um sucesso de vendas
com receitas anuais superando os 3
bilhões de dólares até 2006 contudo o
que pare ser um sonho se transformou
rapidamente no pesadelo médico e ético
em 2007 um estudo publicado pela New
England Journal of medicine revelou um
lado obscuro do avania A análise
envolvendo mais de 14.000 pacientes
indicou que o medicamento aumentava em
42% risco cardiovascular em usuários de
longo prazo os resultados foram
chocantes riscos significativamente
aumentados de ataques cardíacos e morte
cardiovascular essas descobertas
obrigaram o fda a agência reguladora
Americana a restringir severamente o
acesso ao medicamento em 2010 outras
análises mostraram que os pacientes
medicados com avandia tinha um maior
risco de sofrer infarto insuficiência
cardíaca e de morte por todas as causas
do que os que tomaram outros remédios
para diabetes da mesma classe na Europa
a resposta foi ainda mais drástica o
avandia foi completamente banido no
entanto a controvérsia não parou por aí
a fda anunciou posteriormente que estava
reconsiderando essas restrições
baseando-se em uma revisão de um estudo
de 2 9 conduzido pela gsk fabricante do
medicamento apesar das afirmações da
fabricante de que os dados eram
tranquilizadores e seguros críticas
severas emergiram por exemplo o Dr
Thomas marciniak um cientista da fta
apontou que a empresa havia ignorado
vários casos de efeitos adversos graves
nos dados apresentados a situação se
agravou quando em 2010 o jornal New York
Times revelou que a fabricante do Avan
não só havia ocultado dados negativos
como também manipulado informações para
beneficiar a imagem do medicamento no
mesmo ano a Anvisa suspendeu o uso de
avand em todo o Brasil em 2012 a
farmacêutica admitiu culpa em uma
acusação de fraude por não relatar
problemas de segurança relacionados ao
avandia a verdadeira extensão do impacto
do avandia nas vidas dos pacientes pode
nunca ser completamente conhecida
medicamento cinco trovan a
trovafloxacina
experimento terrível na África em 1996
um caso particularmente chocante marcou
a Indústria Farmacêutica a Pfizer uma
das gigantes do setor estava
desenvolvendo um novo antibiótico o
trovan a Trova floxacina promissor no
tratamento de uma gama vasta de
infecções e com a vantagem de poder ser
administrado por via oral ao invés de
ser por injeção no entanto o que se
seguiu foi uma série de eventos que
mancharam profundamente a mutação da
empresa durante uma epidemia de meningit
na Nigéria a farmacêutica viu uma
oportunidade ideal para testar o
medicamento 200 crianças doentes foram
recrutada para um estudo metade recebeu
trovan e a outra metade sexona um
medicamento já estabelecido pra doença
Infelizmente o desfecho Foi trágico ao
final do estudo 11 crianças haviam
morrido cinco do grupo trovan e seis do
grupo
sexona Além disso muitas outras ficaram
com sequelas graves o cenário já era
desolador mas os detalhes adicionais
revelaram uma situação ainda mais grave
os participantes do estudo crianças
vulneráveis em um momento de crise
sanitária não foram informadas de que
estavam participando do experimento elas
e seus pais acreditavam estar recebendo
ajuda humanitária Além disso foi
evidenciado que as crianças do grupo
controle que receberam o CF trixon foram
sub doos ou seja receberam uma dose bem
menor da medicação numa tentativa de
manipulação para favorecer os resultados
a favor do trovan essa conduta não
apenas violou princípios éticos
fundamentais como também expôs as
Crianças A riscos inaceitáveis diante da
deteriorização
visível da saúde dos pequenos pacientes
Nenhuma medida foi tomada para alterar o
custo do tratamento o resultado foi uma
ação judicial que culminou em um acordo
no qual a farmacêutica concordou em
pagar 75 milhões de dólares
esse caso não é apenas uma história de
uma pesquisa científica mal conduzida é
um relato de desumanidade e manipulação
onde os interesses comerciais
prevaleceram sobre a segurança e o
bem-estar dos mais vulneráveis o trovan
uma vez visto como a promessa médica
tornou-se um símbolo de uma das mais
sombrias facetas da pesquisa
farmacêutica esses exemplos são apenas a
ponta do iceberg Há muitos outros
medicamentos cujos efeitos colaterais
graves só foram descobertos após
causarem danos irreversíveis
infelizmente ainda existem casos que
talvez nunca venhamos a conhecer
completamente escondidos atrás de
estudos incompletos ou dados manipulados
essa realidade serve como lembrete
Sombrio da importância da Transparência
e da integridade na pesquisa e na
comercialização de novos medicamentos
Além disso é fundamental reavaliar a
nossa abordagem ao tratamento de
condições crônicas muitas vez a solução
não reside apenas no uso prolongado de
medicamentos mas na revisão do estilo de
vida do paciente e na Restauração do
organismo é essencial que como
Profissionais de Saúde iniciemos o
tratamento de doenças crônicas com
métodos que são mais gentis e naturais
recorrendo a medicamentos mais
agressivos somente quando estritamente
necessário esse equilíbrio entre o
natural e farmacológico não apenas pode
melhorar a qualidade de vida do paciente
mas também Minimizar riscos potenciais
associados ao uso de medicamentos
compartilhe os vídeos faço bem a vida de
alguém pode mudar também no canal da t
além do TR se vvar